Mr. President, the
British are suffering from
increasingly more
dangerous cyberattacks.
The Thames barrier has failed,
causing the worst floods in the
capital for over a century.
The operators think someone
got into the system.
We've been tracking the suspect.
We think it's connected
to a terrorist plot.
Facial recognition identifies
him as Gabriel Delage.
I should be calling
the cops right now.
Mm-hmm, you should.
I've been seeing someone
for the past five years,
and we're going
to get married.
Does he know about everything?
No.
This holds the attack plans.
The attack already took place.
No, that was a warning.
Until somebody
claims responsibility,
the job isn't over.
And you trust this man?
After what you did to him?
I guess you must
hate me to death.
I'm trying to tell you
that I've changed.
You think people change?
It's happening again.
The complete control
of the grid.
We have to get a grip
of this, Alison.
I need you.
I know those guys
more than you do.
They're going to slaughter us.
If you stay here,
you'll die.
I know that they're
preparing an attack,
and I'm supposed
to run away?
Who do you take me for?